Bonjour. Aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'iPhone 9.
La question pourrait paraître un peu
prématurée à parler de toutes les
rumeurs sur l'iPhone 9 mais pourtant
il y a un vrai sens. L'iPhone X,
l'iPhone 8 et 8 Plus viennent à peine d'être
annoncée par Apple que l'on parle déjà
du futur iPhone 9.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'avec
l'iPhone X on a entraperçu
l'avenir des nouveaux iPhone et on va
vraiment passer à tout autre chose.
Je suis Monsieur GRrr. Pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ma chaîne parle de stratégie digitale,
de stratégie Youtube et de tous les objets
d' influence qui vous permettront
d'aller plus loin dans votre vie
digitale. Je vous invite à vous
abonner à ma chaîne et à activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune
publication.
L'iPhone 10 nous annonce
la fin de tous ces smartphones.
Du 3g S qui a fait son temps,
avec une forme qui est obsolète.
Du 4, du 5C, du 6S, du 7,
du 8. C'est la fin de cette gamme d'iPhone.
A la place que va t'on retrouver ?
On va avoir des grands écrans OLED.
C'est la fin du LCD sur les iPhone.
Ils ont fait leur temps.
Apple les a remercié et leur a dit au revoir.
A la place ils s'approvisionnent
maintenant avec des écrans OLED.
Les écrans OLED de
l'iPhone x sont fournis par leur
grand concurrent sud coréen Samsung.
C'est toujours un compliqué pour une
société comme Apple de faire travailler
son concurrent principal directement.
Samsung Electronics fournit les écrans OLED de l'iPhone X.
Ils sont les seuls aujourd'hui en capacité de
fournir des écrans en grande quantité.
Selon une information du site économique
coréen tThe Investor, Apple aurait déjà
passé commande de plus de 180 millions
d'écrans pour son futur smartphone de 2018.
Ce serait Samsung mais Apple aurait une autre idée en la tête.
Actuellement les écrans OLED sont disponibles sur les smartphones
Samsung mais également LG. LG n'aurait
pas la capacité industrielle de
fabriquer autant d'écrans OLED que
Samsung mais Apple je soutiendrais LG
afin qu'il puisse produire davantage
d'écrans OLED en grande quantité.
Pour quelle raison ?
Parce que si vous avez deux concurrents
en compétition les prix
des écrans OLED vont baisser. Il faut
savoir que pour fabriquer un iphone X,
un écran OLED coûte entre
120 à 130 dollars alors que le smartphone
est vendu 999 dollars. Soit environ près de 12 % du prix de vente.
C'est conséquent. Si LG et Samsung
étaient en concurrence les prix
baisseraient. Apple pourrait soit augmenter sa marge, soit
diminuer les prix de ses téléphones.
Ils seraient alors plus concurrentiels.
L'action de Samsung a monté
lorsque l'iphone X est sortie qu'il a été
bien accueilli par le public.
Le coût de fabrication des écrans LCD
était de 50 dollars.
Il y avait une vraie concurrence entre
plusieurs entreprises asiatiques.
Apple jouait sur la concurrence et ça permettait de baisser les prix.
Que va t'on retrouver dans ces nouveaux iPhone ?
La nouveauté sera la taille de l'écran.
Deux smartphones sortiraient en 2018.
Un modèle avec un écran de 5,28 pouces et un autre de 6,46 pouces.
Ils seraient équipés du nouveau processeur A12 qui permettrait de progresser dans la réalité augmentée,
dans le temps de calcul, dans l'optimisation de votre matériel.
Cette puce serait créée soit par la société
taïwanaise TSMC qui créait
des puces depuis de nombreuses années
pour Apple,
soit par Samsung qui pourrait créer la nouvelle puce du prochain iPhone.
Le Touch ID disparaitrait des iPhone au profit du Face ID.
Une rumeur persistante au sujet de l'iPhone
X faisait était d'un bouton Home virtuel sous l'écran.
La technologie n'aurait pas été suffisamment bien développée pour pouvoir le mettre sur ce smartphone.
Est-ce qu'il sera présent sur les prochains
smartphones en complément du Face ID ?
La question reste en suspend.
Le Face ID va s'imposer et Touch ID va disparaître.
Selon Mac Rumors LG pourrait développer les batteries du futur iphone.
Des batteries en L qui prendraient moins de place à l'intérieur
et qui permettraient d'optimiser le hardware de ce smartphone.
Il pourrait être proposée en 64 Go, 256 Go et 512 Go.
Il se rechargerait à l'induction.
La recharge avec un cable va de toutefaçon disparaitre et faire partie du passé comme tous ces anciens iPhone.
On retrouverait une caméra grand angle et un téléobjectif. On monterait en qualité
pour gagner en luminosité et en qualité
pour vos vidéos ou sur vos photos.
La réalité augmentée sera toujours plus présente.
Tim Cook adore la réalité augmentée,
il mise dessus.
Actuellement c'est encore un gadget.
On a vu les présentations où l'on peut jouer
à des jeux en se déplaçant autour.
Mais il faut vraiment considérer ça
comme une avancée technologique majeure.
La réalité augmentée va être
omniprésente.
Vous l'utiliserez quand vous irez faire vos courses au supermarché.
Vous aurez plus d'informations sur vos produits.
Lorsque vous irez voir une exposition vous aurez davantage d'informations.
La réalité augmentée sera présente dans votre quotidien.
Actuellement c'est encore un gadget mais dites-vous que d'ici quelques années
ce sera impossible de passer à
côté de la réalité augmentée.
Alors quid de la réalité virtuelle ?
Il y avait une rumeur qui avait circulée
disant que l'iPhone de 2018 pourrait être équipé de
petits connecteurs pour le connecter à un casque de réalité virtuelle.
Ces rumeurs ne sont pas concrètes actuellement
mais la réalité virtuelle va énormément se développer.
On peut un casque de réalité virtuelle qui vous permettra
d'avoir de la réalité augmentée "mains libres".
Vous porteriez votre casque de
réalité virtuelle.
Votre smartphone serait bien évidemment dessus et vous pourriez voir votre pièce
grâce à la caméra de votre smartphone.
Ca existe sur Samsung et j'ai pu l'essayer.
La qualité n'est pas extraordinaire et
on a rapidement la nausée mais imaginez
que si vous aviez une qualité
exceptionnelle au niveau de votre
caméra avec un écran oled
et un rendu exceptionnel.
Ca vous permettrait de superposer des objets. D'avoir une réalité augmentée encore plus intéressante.
Ca vous éviterait de tenir votre smartphone à la main.
Vous auriez votre casque sur la tête.
Si vous étiez dans la rue ou à une exposition vous auriez l'air bête
mais ça peut être vraiment
intéressant.
Il y a aussi un autre projet qui
est en développement ce sont les Apple Glass.
Ce seraient des lunettes qui permettraient d'avoir de la réalité augmentée.
J'ai essayé à l'IFA de Berlin le casque de
réalité augmentée de Microsoft
et on en reparle très bientôt
mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant.
La technologie n'est pas encore très aboutie mais c'est vraiment bluffant.
Comment vont s'appeler les iPhone du
futur ?
Avec l'arrivée de l'iPhone X on va très bien que la dénomination classique des iPhone va changer.
6, 6S, 7. Pas de 7S, directement 8, 8 Plus
et là l'iPhone X.
Le nom des iPhone avec une numérotation
classique va disparaître.
Apple ne sortira pas un iPhone 9 l'année prochaine alors que l'iPhone X est déjà  sorti.
On ne va pas arriver directement à
l'iPhone11. Ca n'aurait pas de sens.
Qu'est ce que cela peut bien vouloir dire pour Apple ?
Si l'on va chercher dans l'histoire d'Apple et
dans l'histoire des produits d'Apple et
notamment de Mac OS,
on a des éléments de réponse.
Si vous êtes utilisateur d'Apple depuis longtemps vous savez que les Mac OS avant
s'appelait Mac OS 8, Mac OS 9.
Il y avait des mises à jour avec le 9.2 ...
Cette vieille machine, qui est un vieux dinosaure d'Apple,
c'est le dernier qui a tourné avec un système 9.2 et le premier sur lequel j'ai installé Mac OS X.
Il se pourrait qu'il se passe exactement la même chose sur les iPhone
par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé pour Mac OS.
Il y avait les versions 8, la version 9. L'arrivée ensuite de Mac OS X.
Après il y a eu une déclinaison :
Mac OS X 1, 2, 3, 4 ...
Cheetah, Puma, Jaguar, Panther, 10.4
Tiger, 10.5 Leopard, 10.6 Snow Leopard,
10.5 Lion, Mountain Lion,
Maverick, Yosemite, El capitan, Sierra, High Sierra.
Il pourrait se passer exactement
la même chose pour les iPhone.
On peut imaginer avoir un iPhone X et
ensuite que vous n'ayez plus de numérotation
mais des noms qui permettent de les reconnaître.
On pourrait imaginer un iPhone Jaguar. Un
iPhone Maverick. IPhone Yosemite.
Ce serait probablement plus sympa
qu'avoir un simple numéro.
On ne va pas se retrouver avec l'iPhone
31, l'iPhone 32, ...
Cette numérotation n'a plus réellement de
sens.
Ces iPhone seraient moins cher par rapport au prix de l'iPhone X.
Il devrait coûter moins de 1000 dollars.
Le problème principal actuel du coût de ce smartphone est le prix de ses écrans OLED.
Le coût de fabrication est trop élevé.
Si LG arrive à se développer et à produire à grande échelle,
on devrait avoir des iPhone
beaucoup moins cher.
C'est un élément clé pour Apple.
Samsung maîtrise la chaîne de fabrication de ces écrans.
Leurs smartphones seront donc moins cher bien que le Galaxy S8 et S8+
et le Note 8 sont quand même relativement cher.
Mais Samsung sera toujours plus
concurrentiel puisque ils n'ont pas de sous-traitants
pour leurs écrans et que
ce sont leurs propres écrans.
Si Apple veut rester concurrentiel
ils vont devoir baisser les prix d'achat de leurs écrans.
Cet iPhone pourrait coûter 1000 dollars environ.
Peut-être un moins pour l'écran 5,28 pouces.
Cela est encore hypothétique, il
est trop tôt pour avoir des informations précises.
Cet iPhone sortirait en septembre 2018.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaire.
Est ce que vous êtes séduit par l'iPhone 8?
Est-ce que vous envisageriez de
l'acheter ?
Si vous avez un iPhone 7, à moins  que vous soyez vraiment un gros fan de réalité augmentée,
ça ne vaut pas le coup d'acheter l'iPhone 8 aujourd'hui.
Surtout que l'année prochaine il y aura vraiment des évolutions.
Les nouveautés de l'iPhone X équiperont tous les prochains iPhone.
Si vous achetez un iPhone 8 aujourd'hui, il va devenir rapidement obsolète.
Par contre si vous avez un iPhone 5C, un iPhone 5S, un iPhone 6, 6S
ça peut être intéressant d'acheter un iPhone 8. Si vous avez besoin d'une bonne qualité au niveau de la caméra,
si vous avez besoin d'un processeur un petit peu plus rapide.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire.
Est-ce que vous envisagez de changer votre iPhone ?
Si oui pour lequel ?
Que pensez-vous de ce que pourrait être
ce futur iPhone 9 ?
L'iPhone 10 Cheetah ? L'iPhone 10 Jaguar ? J'attends vos commentaires et on en discute ensemble.
Je vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Je vous invite à vous abonner à ma chaîne car il y aura toujours plus de contenu pour
réussir votre vie digitale. Que ce soit
votre stratégie Youtube ou
pour connaître les nouveaux produits d'influence, les nouvelles fonctionnalités intéressantes.
Abonnez-vous à ma chaîne.
Merci d'abord regarder cette vidéo. Si vous avez des questions
vous pouvez me contacter sur twitter @MonsieurGRrr avec le hashtag #ASKMonsieurGRrr
Je vous dis à très bientôt d'ici là portez vous bien.
Salut !